dans trois mois à peine où serait en
première ligne
vous donnerez des ordres des hommes plus
âgés que vous
sachez que votre réussite sera
primordiale car elle aura des
conséquences sur l'issue de cette guerre
contre la neige
vous avez l'ordre de vous déplacer vers
la ligne et de retenir l'ennemi jusqu'à
l'arrivée de renforts ce qui va prendre
cinq ou six jours
je trouverai je ferai tout pour
aujourd'hui
après la noue
outre on résiste
je crains qu'une la tanière plus
longtemps que prévu
[Musique]
à beaucaire
mais des jours tout le monde
bien on tombe dans le meilleur groupe
d'artillerie
tombe aliochine votre infanterie et ma
dernière chance
[Musique]
aura bientôt plus aucun au coeur ils
étaient trois mille cinq cents
[Musique]
qu'il en soit ainsi